chose mystérieuse le temps que
nous ayons tous à la fois de la lumière
et de l'obscurité à l'
intérieur de nous
ce qui compte est la partie sur laquelle nous avons choisi d'agir
c'est qui nous sommes vraiment
je ne serais pas la personne que je suis sans tant
de gens ici
il y a quelque chose à propos de harry potter
qui  rend la vie plus riche
nous sommes une famille et nous ferons toujours partie
de la vie de l'autre
slam vous savez ce que nous avons fait
beaucoup aussi était que oh mon dieu alors
ouais avec comme nous tous comme le rouge comme le
rouge je pense que toutes sortes de connaissances
ouais je me souviens de la version shin
ouais
[Musique]
ils ont probablement rendu leur travail plus difficile pour
eux-mêmes en nous laissant nous amuser autant
que nous en avions parce que cela nous distrayait
de
vous savez le travail que nous étions censés
faire et pour les autres téléspectateurs
comme un gros problème était comme tout au long d'une
prise notre attention
aimerait diminuer et aller et venir  ils disent un
li  ne et puis ils souriaient à la caméra
ou ils étaient tellement heureux d'être dans un
film de Harry Potter qu'ils ne pouvaient pas
contenir leur excitation assez longtemps pour se
concentrer sur une scène entière
[Musique]
pensez à ce souvenir puissant
faites-en
le  le plus heureux dont vous vous souveniez,
c'est comme si aucun temps ne s'était
écoulé et de nombreuses fois passées,
je pense que c'est le moment idéal pour
s'asseoir avec tout le monde et se remémorer
[Musique]
la chose qui m'a le plus effrayé
était l'implication que la chose la plus
significative dans notre  la vie était finie
et il y a quelque chose de si joyeux à
voir tout le monde
et être comme
s'il n'y en avait pas bien que l'
un des moments forts de ma partie ait été
quand j'ai dû faire semblant d'être hermione
prétendant être un meilleur tour je
n'aime pas qu'on me fasse attendre je  "j'ai encore
les dents en fait je vais les mettre si
tu veux
ma soeur a des enfants qui ont eu
environ 10 11 12 ans et j'ai dit maths je ne sais pas
pour ce voldemort ce qu'on
te demande de jouer à voldemort
toi '  je dois le faire
je ne serais pas le p  Personne, je suis sans tant
de monde ici,
c'est une chose très écrasante parce que
je t'ai vu grandir et j'ai
vu toutes les étapes de ta vie
quand les choses deviennent vraiment sombres et que les temps
sont vraiment durs, il y a quelque chose à propos de
Harry Potter qui fait  la vie est plus riche c'est
un lien fort que nous aurons toujours
nous sommes une famille et nous ferons toujours partie
de la vie de l'autre
[Musique]
toi